Transcriber: Mahmood Alsaffar
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
لطالما سألت نفسي
أين سأكون  بعد خمس سنوات؟
لكني ام أحلم يوماً، أن أصل الى ما وصلت
إليه اليوم، و لو بعد 20 سنة قادمة
فاطمة رزج، طبيبة من الحزكة،
ماجستير في إدارة ألأعمال.
بدأت ألحكاية منذ خمس سنوات بالضبط،
حين قررت أنا و زوجي و طفلي ألصغير
الإنتقال للعيش في اللاذقية، بغية إستكمال
زوجي دراساته العليا في جامعة دشة
سافرنا بأحلام عريضة، كان أخرها بأننا بعد
عام سنملك سيارتنا الخاصة لننتقل إلى
الكورنيش ونستمتع بمشهد البحر.
لم نكن نعلم بأننا سنعود صفر اليدين
معدمين وتحت خط الفقر.
بدأت رحلة البحث عن عمل.
كانت الرحلة شاقة.
أكثر من المتوقع ستة أشهر من
البحث المضني دون جدوى،
كان آخرها بأنني وجدت فرصة للعمل
في أكبر المراكز في اللاذقية،
لأكتشف بأن الراتب لطبيب بدوام صباحي مسائي
لا يتجاوز ال65 ألف ليرة.
هذا المبلغ في ذلك الوقت لا يكفي حليب ابني
الذي لا يتجاوز الستة أشهر آنذاك.
والحليب،
قصة أخرى.
كانت اللاذقية تعاني من انقطاع
شبه تام في الحليب.
كنا نتقاسم الحليب، أنا وزوجي في رحلة البحث
عن علبة حليب لا تكفي لأيام حتى.
بحثت عن عمل ثاني وثالث ورابع دون جدوى.
في ذلك الوقت بدأت بدراسة ماجستير إدارة
الأعمال كنوع من أنواع الهروب من الواقع
وتحقيق لحلم قديم.
تعرضت لبعض الانتقادات،
فما هي علاقة إدارة الأعمال بالطب؟ لأجد
بعدها فرصة إدارية في أحد الشركات التجميلية
فاعتقدت بأنني قد وجدت فرصة الأحلام.
خضعت للمقابلة.
شرح لي المدير أساسيات العمل.
كنت أول الواصلين في اليوم التالي
لأكتشف بأن العمل هو عكس ما
شرح لي تماما، وأن
علي أن أحمل حقيبة من المنتجات التجارية
وأدور بها بين المنازل وأقنع الناس بالشراء.
قضيت يومي أقنع النساء بشراء مسكر زيت
الثعبان لتقويةرموش، حقيقة شعرت بخيبةكبيرة.
قضيت الطريق الواصل للمنزل في البكاء، أردد
في نفسي هل هذا هو المكان الذي كنت
أحلم أن أكون فيه قبل خمس سنوات؟ بدأت
بعدها بمشروع لتجارة الألبسة بين الحزكة
و اللاذقية.
أنشأت حسابا وهميا على الفيسبوك.
مجموعة واتساب بدأت بها بنشر البضائع تباعا.
فشل المشروع فشلا ذريعا بسبب مشاكل
الشحن بين المنطقتين .
وصل بي الحال أنني أنشأت حساب
على أحد مواقع العمل الحر.
هذه المواقع تتطلب أن تقدم
خدمة مقابل خمسة دولار.
بدأت بتعلم الفوتوشوب على أمل أن أبدأ العمل
فاكتشفت أنه يتطلب مني الكثير من
الوقت و أنا لا أملك الكثير من الوقت.
سنة كاملة من الخذلان.
سنة كاملة من الخيبة.
سنة كاملة انكسارات.
مصروف عائلة بدون أي وارد.
قررت أن أعود للحزك.
زوجة بعيدة عن زوجها طفل بعيد عن أبيه.
حرفيا كنا قد عدنا إلى نقطة الصفر.
بدأت بالتقدم إلى أي فرصة عمل تواجهني
في المحافظة، كان أخرها بأنني تقدمت إلى
مدخل بيانات في أحد الجمعيات المحلية.
وقد رفضت بالطبع طبيبة، ماجستير
في إدارة الأعمال.
أغلقت كل الأبواب في وجهي،
حتى اقترح علي أحد الزملاء أن أفتتح
عيادة عن طريق الأقساط الشهرية.
هذا الخيار لم يكن واردا فلم أملك
ما يمكنني من هذه الخطوة.
عيادة عن طريق الأقساط، أي أملك حوالي أربعة
الاف دولار، وأن لا أملك دولاراً واحدا حتى.
عيادة عن طريق الأقساط، أي أملك
نصف من المبلغ يدفع الباقي عن طريق الأقساط.
لا أعلم أي قوة جاءتني لأذهب و أقابل مدير
الشركة وأطلب منه عيادة بدون أي قسط شهري.
ولأن من أدمن قرع الباب أوشك أن يفتح له،
جاءت الموافقة
والتي كانت البداية لكل ما تقدم.
بدأت بعيادة بسيطة وإمكانيات بسيطة وأحلام
كبيرة، شرعت بتطبيق مبادئ الإدارة
والإدارة المالية والتسويق.
أنشأت مجموعة أنشأت صفحة على الفيسبوك
وبدأت بنشر الحالات تباعا.
بعد عام انتقلت إلى مكان أكبر
وبدأت الأحلام تكبر.
لم تكن المهمة سهلة بالطبع،
أن تكوني المديرة
والزوجة والطبيبة والأم في الوقت ذاته.
في العام الذي تلاه أعلنت عن افتتاح أول
وأكبر مركز طبي في المحافظة
بكادر يتجاوز ال30 شخص
وفريق إعلام مسؤول عن إدارة الصفحة.
نشر المحتوى كتابة المنشورات
نشر الحالات تباعا.
عيادة تتألف من عيادة طب أسنان
بأطباء من مختلف الاختصاصات،
عيادة للتغذية، عيادة لليزر،
تحوي أحدث إصدارات الليزر في المنطقة.
عيادة للتغذية والعلاج الفيزيائي، والصيدلية
تحوي منتجات من أشهر الماركات العالمية
لم تكن المهمة سهلة بالطبع، ولم يكن ذلك
وليد الصدفة، بل كان نتاج عمل مثمر
وأيام شاقة،
رسالتي للشباب الذي اتخذ من
الأزمة شماعة التقاعس.
“من المستحيل” مجرد كلمة
و ألشكر
(تصفيق)